well if you thought the hate mob
yesterday was going to stop with Donald
Trump Jr and Candace Owens
that's bad enough by the way it didn't
last night Sean Hannity Fox News
propagandist took a break from
interviewing Donald Trump in order to
direct the hate mob against me and it
led to yet another round of insane
threats and anti-Semitism anti-Semitism
which by the way the daily wires Michael
Knowles says I made up which in five
minutes I will show you is sadly very
much not made up but let's not start
with that right now Sean Hannity jumping
on the bandwagon and attacking me but
interestingly he doesn't even actually
quote me or show my tweet
he quotes someone talking about my tweet
what kind of production value is this
how pathetic they couldn't even be
bothered take a look at this didn't stop
there one awful Progressive talk show
host quote joking about the victims not
praying enough that's supposed to be
funny I thought attacking one's personal
religious beliefs was not allowed in the
leftist woke world we live in yeah so up
on the screen is a quote by someone
named Kendall tits or she's Kendall
teets I have to admit I don't actually
know how it's How It's pronounced and it
says it's a quote from Kendall
Progressive talk show host David packman
mocked the Covenant School Community for
not praying enough of course that's not
what I did I pointed out that prayers
don't work to stop mass shootings
Hannity can't even be bothered to show
the Tweet he just goes I don't know I'll
quote Kendall teets or Kendall tits what
the hell is wrong with these people and
of course another wave of anti-Semitism
always Focus on me being Jewish and by
the way by the way by the way uh I'm
going to talk about the anti-Semitism
stuff in a moment but you know I I
received a lot of messages of support
overnight and I'm going to talk about
some of those a little bit later
unless you are on the receiving end of
the sort of barrage that these
right-wing people do it is every
platform it's a thousand posts on
Instagram
it's a thousand emails it's a hundred
thousand tweets directed at you one a
second
you step away for a half hour and look
and then there's thousands more just
endless endless these
borderline riotous mobs that are in the
audience of folks like Sean Hannity so
there it is Hannity jumping in on the
action creating another barrage and now
what I want to get there oh and by the
way
so many people signing up at
joinpackman.com with the coupon code
cancel canceled these people like
Hannity and others they claim to be
against canceling and yet now for 48
hours they've been running campaigns to
try to get me canceled by writing to my
advertisers the number of people I am
flattered and I will delve into this
later who did go to joinpakman.com after
I mentioned it yesterday and signed up
using the coupon code cancel cancel like
cancel the cancelers
stunning numbers and we're going to get
to that a little bit later